[музика]
ми здається вже почали заняття здається
друзі вже нас дивляться ну швиденько
Доїдай
Вибачте я щось забувся що то вже заняття
почалося
Привіт друзі ми з вами сьогодні будемо
вчити щось дуже цікаве А знаєте що А ось
те
що є будемо вчити Як береться хлібчик от
ми його отримали ми його їмо
А як він виготовляється звідки це все
береться Мені дуже цікаво а то я знаю що
його можна купити в магазині та й більше
нічого не знаю давайте дізнаємось
давайте друзі дізнаємось разом Давай
Тож давайте ми сьогодні з вами
уважно послухаємо
ємо звідки береться хліб
Почнемо ми з того що
у нас є земля так ось у нас є ґрунт
давайте разом повторимо грунт ще раз
грунт молодці Ось у нас є земля
так
і в цю землю ми з вами
засіваємо насіння
[музика]
засіваємо насіння як і в принципі будь
куди Так коли ми хочемо щоб щось виросло
якесь рослина пригадуйте ми з вами вже
про це говорили раніше І от коли
засівається
насіння
ферми це роблять на полях таких
просторих без край їх полях
з часом
виростають такі
колоски давайте повторимо колоски це є
колоски пшениці і
у кожному
з цих колосочків
дозріває
насіннячко це власне є пшениця Я ось тут
друзі пшениці не мала але маю рис і воно
є Дуже схоже приблизно такого ж розміру
тільки трішки такого золотішого кольору
і ось друзі
коли пшеничка дозріває бо саме з пшениці
пізніше ми будемо робити хлібчик коли
пшениця дозріває ми починаємо збирати
врожай
це означає що
фермери або комбайном або вручну
збирають оці всі колоски пшениці знаєте
такі великі
оберемки Які наповнені насінням Отож
коли зібрали пшеничку їй відвозять на
спеціальні заводи де її перемелюють у
друзі Ви добре знаєте що це
у борошно Так ви знаєте що таке борошно
бо саме з борошна ми робимо хлібчик і
ось
коли перемололи дуже багато борошна така
мішками їх дуже-дуже багато це борошно
везуть
пекарям У пекарні
пекарі друзі це є люди це їхня професія
які печуть хліб булочки печиво та інше і
вже у пекарні наші пекарі
печуть хлібчик
ось спекли хлібчику таких великих печах
спекли його дуже-дуже багато і опісля
у пекарню до нашого пана пекаря
приїжджає велику вантажівка яка забирає
та й весь хлібчик І знаєте друзі що далі
робить
розвозить у супермаркети у невеличкі
магазини які поруч з вами У пекарні де
можна сісти скуштувати хлібчика і випити
каву чи чаю Ось така історія друзів А
вже у після ви знаєте ви підходите у
магазин обираєте хлібчики і вам
найбільше смакує та й купуєте його так
Ось так друзі Тепер ви знаєте як Ми
виготовляємо хлібчик так І наступного
разу коли ви будете зі своїми друзями
наприклад
куштувати хлібчик то ви собі пригадаєте
у якийсь спосіб Його виготовляють
обіцяєте розказати друзям
Чудово А тепер друзі давайте послухаємо
казочку про
маленьку червону курочку
Але перед тим ми познайомимося з
основними героями цієї казки Отож У нас
є маленька червона курочка
У нас є
сонний котик покажіть такий сонний котик
вусатий У нас є чорна собачка Так
і у нас є гучна качка
Отож друзі давайте наставимо на ще вушка
і будемо слухати історію про маленьку
червону курочку Отож жила собі на фермі
маленька червона курочка і ось одного
дня вона знайшла зернятко таке
малесеньке малесеньке
зернятко так ось в мене тут воно є
знайшла вона зернятко і підійшла до
своїх друзів які разом з нею жили на
фермі
друзі Хто допоможе мені посадити
зернятком
[музика]
сказав наш сонний Котик
не я сказала гучна качка
не я сказала чорна собачка
Ну гаразд посаджу я сама
посадила зернятко І що зернятком сталося
воно виросло так виросла зарядку
ой виросло моє зернятко Хто допоможе
мені зрізати вже готову пшеничку
не я каже гучна качка не я - каже сонний
котик
каже чорна собачка
Ну гаразд зріжу сама
друзі
А ти хто допоможе мені перемолоти мою
пшеничку
друзі Ану зголоситься не я гучна качка
не хочу допомагати
мяу не я сонний котик каже
не я сказав наш песик
[музика]
я зроблю сама ой друзі я вже з молона
нашу пшеничку і тепер у нас є багато
борошна Хто допоможе мені хлібчик спекти
Як ви думаєте малята
що не друзі нашої маленької червоної
курочки
Ну вони сказали не я
не я сказав наш сонний Котик
не я сказала чорна собачка
Друзі Ну гаразд Я сама з пачохлівчик
спекла лише курочка красивий запашний
рум'яний хлібчик
друзі А хто не допоможе мені з'їсти цей
смачний хлібчик Як ви думаєте друзі Хто
допоможе з'їсти
так малята всі
[музика]
тобі з'їсти цей хлібчик і я допоможу
тобі з'їсти хлібчик
і я допомо
жу Ені друзі Тепер я сама їсти саму
хлібчик бо ви мені не допомагали його
готувати тож із ім'ям його сама Ось така
історія малюки бачите зверталася Наша
курочка до друзів за допомогою А вони не
допомагали і відповідно курочка вирішила
з'їсти хлібчик якийсь спекла самостійно
ось
[музика]
ми вже майже закінчуємо наше заняття з
вами однак допоможіть мені порахувати
всіх наших героїв нашої казочки от
подивіться у мене тут є
качечки у вигляді прикладу їх тут у нас
є скільки давайте полічимо
один два тут і один два тут два додати
два дві качечки додати дві качечки
скільки буде разом
молодці 4 Давайте ми напишемо у прикладі
4 правильно
дуже добре і давайте ми візьмемо ще один
приклад Ух У нас тут є дуже багато наших
собачок Давайте ми порахуємо скільки тут
їх є з одного боку і з іншого боку
приклада один два три чотири чотири
додати 1 2 3 4 5 6 4 + 6 такий великий
приклад скільки буде
Давайте подумаємо
молодці 10 Давайте ми перевіримо
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 4 + 6 = 10 дуже
добре друзі Ви великі молодці
Я думаю ми можемо вже гукати наше Совеня
і завершувати заняття правда
[музика]
Совеня
Совеня ти де
от є тут
Ну як сподобалось вам історія про
хлібчик А про курочку До речі я її знаю
Це моя дуже близька подруга ми разом з
нею колись готували булочки
Ось так бачите Совеня дружить Багато з
ким І з нами і з курочкою так угу
Гаразд друзі давайте закінчувати
прощаємося па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі Всім привіт з вами
науковиця Соломія та науковця Сьогодні
ми експериментуємо і давайте подивимось
що у нас тут є що до нас прийшло в гості
яйце ми зараз будемо вчити наших куряче
яйце плавати давайте Отож нам потрібно
склянка нам потрібна вода
ложка і сіль так і сіль Отож беремо
вибираємо склянку
з водою
Отож тепер кладемо сюди яйце
ще не вміємо не дуже яйце вміє плавати
так собі йому виходить Добре давайте ми
тепер додамо супер інгредієнт в нашу
воду чарівний інгредієнт який
називається сіль кухонна Так зараз я
витягну яйце з води Давай ходи яєчко
будемо вчитися плавати по-іншому так
трохи води розлилося давай останку
візьми додай та багато додай не стидайся
додай кілька ложок солі один
два три Давай ще одну
і так давай ложку перемішаємо тепер
Можна я перемішаю я теж хочу брати
участь
так мішаємо мішаємо мішаємо мішаємо
знаєш що нам стидатися давайте ще
візьмемо солі
замало не буде так додаємо наших чарівну
можна всю банку так давайте тепер
перевіримо чи наше яйце буде плавати чи
знову в тоне ще не буде боятися
це не буде боятися
так
і тепер Ну що яйку Ти готова
та-дам що Яйце робить
А чому воно не тоне бо ми такі чарівниці
через
сіль дивіться друзі Що відбувається
завдяки тому що ми додали багато солі до
звичайної питної води
утворилися скажемо так більше щільність
води коли ми додаємо сіль у воду Вода
стає щільніша там стає набагато більше
молекул таких малесеньких малесеньких
частинок які по суті тримають наше яйце
на горі наче ручками знаєте і тому наше
яйце не тоне тому наприклад плавати коли
ми вчимося плавати значно легше у
морській воді бо вона із соленою і також
відповідно щільнішою Там є багато
молекул які не сприймають на воді і
складніше є вчитися плавати наприклад у
басейні Ось така історія друзів завдяки
молекулам яких я б значно більше у
соленій воді завдяки солі наша яйця
тримається на плаву І що робить
Ось так друзі спробуйте вдома і скажіть
нам чи Вам вдалося Ну що ж будемо
прощатися всім Гарного дня
[музика]